en pleine crise mondiale de l'énergie
des discussions ont eu lieu entre la
russie et l'union européenne le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov a rencontré l'association des
entreprises européennes les détails
c'est avec maylis d'estrées
correspondante à moscou
lors de cette rencontre annuelle sergueï
lavrov n'a pas manqué d'aborder une des
grandes préoccupations actuelles en
europe à savoir la flambée des prix du
gaz à ce sujet le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères a déclaré que moscou
était prête à aider l'europe à surmonter
cette crise en soulignant toutefois que
le vieux continent ne devait pas
politiser la question du casse écoutez
dans la situation actuelle de forte
hausse des prix des hydrocarbures en
particulier du gaz naturel et de
l'électricité dans les pays de l'union
européenne il devient évident que nous
devons coopérer de manière beaucoup plus
étroite et systématique dans ce domaine
style
manière plus générale la russie prend
une coopération pragmatique avec l'union
européenne et souhaite rétablir des
contacts réguliers avec elle dans tous
les domaines a ajouté le chef de la
diplomatie russe qui regrette la
dégradation constante des relations
russo européennes ces sept dernières
années aux côtés
nous n'avons pas de grandes attentes
nous comprenons que les choses sont
actuellement allé trop loin et que
personne ne pourra inverser la situation
du jour au lendemain la confiance à
troupe été ébranlé par une série de
mesures unilatérales de la part de
bruxelles mais en même temps nous
considérons qu'il est important de ne
pas aggraver une situation qui est déjà
très très grave
s'est toutefois réjoui que malgré les
sanctions la russie et l'union
européenne restent des partenaires
économiques très importants l'une pour
l'autre